- Bine ai revenit la „Înțelegerea Informației
și Computației Cuantice".
Mă numesc John Watrous și sunt directorul tehnic
al departamentului de Educație la IBM Quantum.
Aceasta este a doua lecție din serie. Dacă nu ai văzut
deja prima lecție, asigură-te că o urmărești.
Vom construi direct pe ceea ce am discutat
în prima lecție, deci este important să înțelegi
acel material înainte de a aborda această lecție.
De asemenea, fii conștient că seria
include conținut din manual pe lângă videoclipuri, și poți găsi un link
către conținutul manualului
în descrierea videoclipului. Aceasta este lecția a doua din
unitatea unu a seriei.
Unitatea unu acoperă noțiunile de bază
ale informației cuantice.
În lecția anterioară, am discutat despre informația cuantică în contextul sistemelor individuale, adică avem un singur
sistem care stochează informație
și descriem cum
funcționează în izolare.
Am petrecut destul de mult timp
pe informația clasică, în principal pentru a stabili un punct de referință și a evidenția similaritățile
matematice
dintre informația cuantică și cea clasică.
Am văzut, de asemenea, cum stările cuantice pot fi reprezentate prin vectori, mai precis vectori cu
intrări de numere complexe și normă euclidiană egală cu unu,
și am discutat despre
măsurătorile în baza standard și operațiile unitare.
În această lecție, vom extinde
perspectiva la sisteme multiple, fiecare dintre ele putând
stoca informație cuantică.
Aceasta nu este pur și simplu o chestiune de a spune că fiecare sistem individual
funcționează așa cum am discutat ultima dată, există un sens în care întregul
este mai mult decât suma părților, și asta este valabil și pentru
informația clasică atunci când sunt implicate probabilități.
Sistemele multiple pot
interacționa unele cu altele și pot fi corelate
unele cu altele, de exemplu, și în contextul cuantic, aceasta include posibilitatea
ca sistemele să fie entangled, un termen pe care
poate l-ai mai auzit înainte.
Entanglementul este un fenomen foarte
important în informația cuantică și vom avea multe de spus despre el pe măsură ce seria continuă.
Există un principiu simplu, totuși, care ne oferă destul de multă tracțiune pentru a gândi și a
înțelege informația cuantică pentru sisteme multiple,
și anume că putem întotdeauna
lua două sau mai multe sisteme și le putem pune împreună sau pur și simplu conceptual
să ne gândim la ele împreună
și să le privim ca și cum formează
un singur sistem compus.
Și când ne gândim la un
sistem compus astfel, ca și cum ar fi un singur sistem, recunoaștem că trebuie descris într-un mod consistent
cu tot ceea ce am învățat
în lecția anterioară despre sistemele individuale.
Vom vedea cum funcționează asta
și cum descrierea informației cuantice
pentru sisteme multiple apare destul de natural din modul în care funcționează pentru sistemele individuale
pe baza acestui unic principiu. Iată o prezentare generală a lecției și se întâmplă să fie identică cu prezentarea generală a lecției anterioare,
dar de data aceasta concentrarea noastră
va fi pe sistemele multiple în loc de sistemele individuale.
La fel cum am făcut în lecția anterioară și din exact aceleași motive, vom începe cu
informația clasică.
Din nou, vom vedea
similarități foarte strânse între modul în care funcționează informația cuantică
și cea clasică la nivel matematic.
Nu vom pune de obicei atât de mult accent pe informația clasică sau nu vom începe fiecare lecție din serie cu informația clasică în acest fel.
Lecțiile ulterioare vor tinde să se concentreze mult mai exclusiv pe informația și computația cuantică.
Dar aici la început
aceasta este o abordare sensibilă și revine la ideea că gândirea despre informația clasică
poate servi ca o sursă valoroasă de îndrumare pentru înțelegerea informației cuantice.
Vom discuta, de asemenea,
conceptul important de produs tensorial în
această parte a lecției.
Produsele tensoriale sunt critic importante în informația cuantică, dar apar și în
contextul clasic.
Apoi vom trece la informația cuantică și, la fel ca în lecția anterioară, vom discuta stările cuantice,
măsurătorile în baza standard,
și operațiile unitare de data aceasta
pentru sisteme multiple.
Vom începe prin a discuta
despre stările clasice ale sistemelor multiple.
Reamintim din lecția anterioară
că o stare clasică a unui sistem este o
configurație a acelui sistem care poate fi recunoscută și
descrisă fără ambiguitate
fără nicio incertitudine sau eroare. Și în termeni matematici, atunci când ne referim la un set de stări clasice,
ne referim pur și simplu la o mulțime finită și nevidă.
Vom începe discuția
despre sisteme multiple presupunând că avem
doar două sisteme X și Y.
X are un set de stări clasice pe care îl vom numi sigma, exact
ca în lecția anterioară, și Y are un set de stări clasice
pe care îl vom numi gamma. Mulțimea sigma și gamma
ar putea fi aceeași mulțime sau ar putea fi diferite,
dar le dăm nume diferite, nu numai pentru că
ar putea fi mulțimi diferite, ci și pentru că ne va ajuta
să menținem claritatea dacă le dăm nume diferite.
Vom descoperi că este
destul de ușor să generalizăm întreaga discuție de la două sisteme la orice număr de sisteme, dar
pornind de la două sisteme,
putem să ne concentrăm pe ideile fundamentale fără să ne pierdem în detalii.
WEBVTT
Acum, imaginează-ți că
punem X și Y unul lângă altul cu X în stânga și Y în dreapta, și privim aceste două sisteme împreună
ca și cum formează un singur sistem compus.
pentru a da acestui nou sistem un nume, îl putem scrie ca o
pereche ordonată astfel, sau putem pur și simplu juxtapune
cele două litere astfel.
Ambele sunt comune și putem
alege pe oricare dorim sau pe cel mai convenabil.
În oricare caz, îl vom citi ca XY.
O întrebare foarte naturală
de pus în acest moment este care sunt stările clasice ale acestui nou sistem compus XY?
Și răspunsul la această întrebare este că setul de stări clasice al lui XY este produsul cartezian al
celor două seturi de stări clasice,
sigma și gamma, pe care
îl poți vedea definit chiar aici.
La un moment dat, X are o stare clasică
care este un element al lui sigma, și Y are o stare clasică
care este un element al lui gamma,
și pur și simplu ne gândim
la aceste două stări împreună ca și cum formează o singură stare, și aceasta este exact noțiunea
pe care produsul cartezian o capturează. Avem două elemente,
unul din fiecare dintre mulțimile noastre, și vrem să ne gândim la
aceste două elemente împreună
ca și cum formează un singur
element dintr-o singură mulțime.
Ca să fim clari, există o ipoteză aici, și anume că știm
care dintre sistemele noastre este X și care este Y,
și nu există nicio confuzie între ele. Nu este important că X se află fizic în
partea stângă și Y în dreapta,
ci mai degrabă că cele două
sisteme sunt distinguibile și că am decis
să le ordonăm astfel doar pentru a putea ține
evidența care e care.
Iată un exemplu foarte simplu în care sigma este alfabetul binar și gamma este mulțimea
care conține cele patru culori de cărți de joc.
Dacă X stochează o valoare binară și Y stochează una din cele patru culori de cărți de joc, atunci există opt
stări clasice posibile
ale perechii XY, pe care
le poți vedea listate chiar aici.
Pentru mai mult de două sisteme, aceasta se generalizează într-un mod direct.
În particular, dacă X1 până la Xn sunt sisteme cu seturi de stări clasice sigma unu până la sigma n respectiv.
Atunci dacă ne imaginăm grupând
cele n sisteme împreună și privind la ele ca un sistem, setul de stări clasice este
dat de produsul cartezian
al celor n seturi de stări clasice
sigma unu până la sigma n.
Așa cum poți vedea chiar aici pe ecran. Produsul cartezian
poate fi definit astfel pentru orice număr de mulțimi.
De exemplu, dacă avem trei sisteme și toate împart alfabetul binar ca set de stări clasice, deci cu alte cuvinte avem trei biți,
atunci există opt
stări clasice posibile ale celor trei biți privite
împreună ca un singur sistem și le poți vedea listate chiar aici.
Fiecare sistem individual poate
fi în starea zero sau unu, și parcurgem toate
combinațiile posibile.
Un n-tuplu de stări clasice poate fi alternativ scris ca un șir în care lăsăm deoparte
parantezele și virgulele, cum vezi chiar aici.
Și acest lucru este deosebit de sensibil când ne gândim la
stările clasice ca simboluri, ca în exemplul foarte comun
al alfabetului binar
la care revenim mereu. Uneori este foarte convenabil să facem asta și tinde să facă
expresiile noastre mai simple
și mai puțin aglomerate. Noțiunea de șir este de fapt formalizată
în termeni matematici prin produse carteziene,
deci acesta este cu adevărat
doar o notație alternativă și nu ceva conceptual diferit.
Ca exemplu, să spunem că avem
10 biți X1 până la X10.
Asta înseamnă că setul de stări clasice al celor 10 biți împreună,
pe care l-ai gândi în mod natural ca un registru de 10 biți
în un calculator de exemplu,
este produsul cartezian zecimal
al alfabetului binar cu el însuși.
Și dacă scriem acele stări ca șiruri, arată cum vezi chiar
aici, sunt 1.024 dintre ele,
deci desigur nu sunt toate listate aici. Aceste trei puncte chiar aici
sunt menite să indice că există un pattern pe care îl poți deduce
și sperăm că înțelegi ideea. Acum există o convenție
pe care o vom urma pentru ordonarea elementelor
mulțimilor de produse carteziene,
și este important să
clarificăm aceasta pentru a reprezenta atât stările probabilistice cât și stările cuantice ca vectori.
Convenția este că
ordonăm elementele mulțimilor de produse carteziene
lexicografic, ceea ce înseamnă practic ordonare de dicționar.
Mai specific, pornim de la ipoteza că fiecare dintre mulțimile individuale din care luăm produsul cartezian are deja propria sa ordonare
și ne gândim la
un n-tuplu sau un șir dat ca și cum ar fi un cuvânt și îi ordonăm alfabetic.
O altă modalitate de a spune asta este că pozițiile dintr-un
n-tuplu sau un șir scad în importanță
de la stânga la dreapta,
la fel ca atunci când scriem numere folosind cifrele de la zero la nouă.
Iată un exemplu menit
să clarifice acest lucru.
Dacă luăm produsul cartezian între mulțimile care conțin
unu, doi și trei și alfabetul binar, obținem o mulțime cu șase elemente
și aici sunt listate în
ordinea care este descrisă.
Toate elementele cu
unu pe prima poziție vin înaintea tuturor elementelor cu doi pe prima poziție și vin înaintea tuturor elementelor
WEBVTT
cu trei pe prima poziție. Și ori de câte ori două elemente
coincid pe prima poziție, apelăm la ordonarea
pe a doua poziție.
Aceasta este deci ordonarea pe care
o folosim pentru produsele carteziene.
Observă că atunci când folosim această convenție și scriem n-tupluri ca șiruri, observăm niște pattern-uri foarte familiare.
De exemplu, produsul cartezian al
alfabetului binar cu el însuși este ordonat cum vezi chiar aici,
și te poți gândi la aceste șiruri ca fiind ordonate numeric dacă iei aceste șiruri
ca encodări binare ale numerelor întregi nenegative și aceasta se generalizează
la orice lungime de șir. Trecând la stările probabilistice, știm deja din lecția anterioară
că o stare probabilistică asociază o probabilitate cu fiecare stare clasică
a unui sistem dat.
Dacă avem un sistem compus în care am luat două sau mai multe sisteme și le privim colectiv ca și cum formează un singur
sistem cum am discutat tocmai,
atunci o stare probabilistică
a acestui sistem compus trebuie să atribuie probabilități elementelor produsului cartezian
ale sistemelor individuale,
seturi de stări clasice. Asta pentru că acesta este
setul de stări clasice al sistemului compus.
De exemplu, presupunând
că X și Y sunt biți, avem acest exemplu de
stare probabilistică a lui XY.
Probabilitatea că amândoi
biții sunt zero este de o jumătate și probabilitatea că amândoi
biții sunt unu este de o jumătate, deci cei doi biți nu sunt niciodată în dezacord.
Este o stare probabilistică validă a lui XY, și o putem alternativ
scrie ca un vector
cum vezi chiar aici și poți vedea că
urmăm convenția pe care am descris-o cu puțin timp în urmă pentru ordonarea acestor stări clasice.
Acesta este un exemplu de
stare probabilistică în care X și Y sunt corelate, și acesta este sensul în care întregul
este mai mult decât suma părților. Cum am sugerat înainte, nu este pur și simplu că avem o stare probabilistică
a lui X și o stare probabilistică a lui Y și le punem împreună, ci mai degrabă mai întâi punem
sistemele împreună
și apoi ne gândim la
stările probabilistice ale sistemului compus.
Pentru a fi mai precis despre
corelațiile dintre sisteme. Începem prin definirea
noțiunii de independență, care este esențialmente
absența corelației.
Aici, de altfel, termenul independență se referă
la independența statistică spre deosebire de independența liniară
a vectorilor de exemplu.
Este o noțiune fundamentală în
probabilitate și statistică.
Dacă avem două sisteme X și Y și avem în vedere o stare probabilistică
a lui XY, atunci spunem că X și Y sunt independente.
Dacă formula pe care
o vezi chiar aici este adevărată pentru orice alegere de stări clasice
a și b ale lui X și Y.
O modalitate de a interpreta această
condiție de independență este că spune că probabilitatea ca X să fie în oricare stare clasică
și probabilitatea ca Y să fie în o altă stare clasică nu au absolut nimic
de-a face una cu cealaltă.
Deci, aflând în ce stare
se află unul dintre sisteme nu afectează
probabilitățile asociate cu stările celuilalt sistem.
Dacă îți imaginezi că alegi aleatoriu
o stare clasică a lui X conform unei proceduri și apoi alegi aleatoriu
o stare clasică a lui Y
conform unei alte proceduri care nu este în niciun fel
conectată la cea pentru X, cum ar fi dacă o persoană aruncă o monedă
și o altă persoană dintr-o
altă cameră aruncă un zar, atunci aceasta este formula
pe care ai folosi-o pentru a obține probabilitățile
pentru diferite combinații
de stări care să apară. Punctul definiției este că independența este
atunci când formula este validă.
Când ne gândim la stările probabilistice în termeni de vectori de probabilitate, există o formulare simplă
a acestei condiții
mai precis, dacă avem o
stare probabilistică a lui XY, pe care o putem exprima ca un
vector în notația Dirac
cum vezi chiar aici. Atunci a spune că X și Y sunt independente este echivalent cu existența
a doi vectori de probabilitate,
ket Phi și ket Psi, care de altfel putem
pur și simplu citi ca Phi și Psi pentru concizie, reprezentând
stări probabilistice ale lui X și Y separat, care satisfac această egalitate
pe care o vezi chiar aici.
Pentru orice alegeri de a și b, este esențialmente o
reformulare a definiției în termeni de vectori.
De exemplu, iată o stare probabilistică
a unei perechi de biți XY pentru care X și Y sunt independente.
Condiția care este
necesară pentru independență este adevărată pentru vectorii
pe care îi vezi chiar aici.
Adică probabilitatea
pentru fiecare setare posibilă a celor doi biți este dată de produsul probabilităților corespunzătoare
pentru biții individuali.
De exemplu, probabilitatea ca ambii
biți să ia valoarea zero este egală cu o șesime, care este egală cu o
pătrime înmulțit cu două treimi,
și la fel pentru
celelalte trei posibilități care pot fi verificate una câte una.
Pentru starea probabilistică pe care am văzut-o mai devreme, pe de altă parte, în care avem
doi biți care sunt mereu de acord și iau valorile zero și
unu cu probabilitatea o jumătate
nu avem independență și de aceea spunem că
biții sunt corelați.
Corelația înseamnă pur și simplu
lipsa independenței.
O modalitate simplă de a argumenta că
cei doi biți nu sunt independenți este să presupunem că sunt și să derivăm o contradicție
mai precis, dacă cei doi
biți ar fi independenți, ar trebui să existe
numerele q0, q1, r0 și r1
WEBVTT
reprezentând probabilități
pentru cei doi biți individuali astfel încât aceste ecuații
chiar aici să fie satisfăcute.
Acestea sunt probabilitățile
care provin din vectorul nostru și acestea sunt
ecuațiile care trebuie să fie adevărate prin condiția de independență,
dar dacă aruncăm o privire la această
a doua egalitate chiar aici, vedem că ea cere ca
q0 înmulțit cu r1 să fie egal cu zero,
dar singura modalitate prin care
produsul a două numere reale poate fi egal cu zero este dacă cel puțin unul dintre acele
numere este el însuși egal cu zero.
Aceasta se numește uneori
proprietatea produsului zero a numerelor reale.
O altă modalitate de a o spune este că produsul a două numere reale nenule
este întotdeauna nenul.
Deci această egalitate chiar
aici implică fie că q0 este egal cu zero, fie că r1 este egal cu zero,
dar din prima și ultima egalitate vedem că niciuna
din acele două alternative nu poate fi adevărată.
Dacă q0 este egal cu zero, atunci acest produs trebuie să fie egal cu zero, dar nu este egal cu zero
și dacă r1 este egal cu zero,
atunci acest produs trebuie să fie egal cu zero, dar nici asta nu este adevărat.
Deci avem o contradicție
și concluzionăm că X și Y nu sunt independente, deci sunt corelate.
Noțiunea de independență
pe care tocmai am discutat-o și mai precis formularea sa în termeni de vectori de probabilitate este strâns legată
de o operație care poate
fi efectuată pe vectori, cunoscută sub numele de produs tensorial.
Produsele tensoriale pot fi
definite nu numai pentru vectori, ci și pentru matrice
și de fapt noțiunea de produs tensorial poate fi definită
pentru multe alte tipuri de
obiecte matematice de asemenea.
Pot fi descrise
într-un mod destul de abstract, care este atât important cât și
util în matematica pură, dar putem și defini
produse tensoriale pentru vectori
într-un mod foarte simplu și concret, și acesta este calea pe care
o vom urma în această lecție.
Dacă avem doi vectori coloană Phi și Psi scriși în formele pe care le vezi aici, unde sigma și gamma sunt orice
alegere de seturi de stări clasice
sau indici dacă preferi, atunci produsul tensorial al acestor vectori este vectorul pe care îl vezi chiar aici.
Parcurgem toate elementele
produsului cartezian al celor două mulțimi, sigma și gamma, iar intrarea acestui
vector care corespunde
fiecărei perechi ab, scrisă
ca un șir chiar aici, este egală cu produsul intrărilor corespunzătoare
ale acestor doi vectori. Cu alte cuvinte, intrarea ab a lui Phi tensorial Psi este produsul intrării a
din Phi și al intrării b din Psi,
și aceasta este semnificația
a ceea ce este scris chiar aici.
În esență, aceasta este aceeași operație pe care am văzut-o cu câteva momente în urmă când am discutat independența
și acum doar îi dăm un nume.
Iată exact același exemplu
pe care l-am văzut cu puțin timp în urmă scris mai explicit în
termeni de produs tensorial.
Din nou, avem că o șesime este egală cu o pătrime înmulțit cu o treime, o doisprezecime este egală cu o pătrime
înmulțit cu o treime și așa mai departe.
Iată, de altfel, câteva
moduri alternative de a scrie produsul
tensorial a doi vectori.
Când folosim notația Dirac și scriem doi keți
unul lângă altul astfel, înseamnă produsul tensorial.
Deci poți să te gândești la produsul tensorial ca la modul implicit de a înmulți doi vectori coloană împreună.
Nu ar avea niciun sens
să te gândești la un produs de vectori coloană ca acesta în termeni de înmulțire de matrice, deoarece dimensiunile nu funcționează,
deci nu există cu adevărat nicio îngrijorare
de ambiguitate aici.
Putem, de asemenea, scrie
produsul tensorial astfel înăuntrul unui ket și înseamnă
exact același lucru.
Este produsul tensorial
al celor doi vectori.
Primul este foarte comun și de fapt este poate mai comun să scrii un produs tensorial astfel fără simbolul produsului tensorial
decât să incluzi simbolul. Al doilea este
definitiv mult mai puțin comun, dar este uneori destul de util mai ales
ca mod de a elimina necesitatea
de paranteze suplimentare în anumite situații.
Putem, de asemenea, exprima
produse tensoriale explicit în termeni de coloane reale de
numere, cum ai chiar aici,
dacă luăm produsul tensorial al acestor doi vectori coloană chiar aici, atunci acesta este vectorul pe care îl obținem
și poți vedea că intrările de aici sunt produse ale intrărilor
provenind din acești doi vectori.
Ordonarea intrărilor
produsului tensorial este consistentă cu
definiția de mai devreme, cu condiția că urmăm convenția
pe care am descris-o mai devreme pentru ordonarea elementelor
mulțimilor de produse carteziene.
Urmând acea convenție este echivalent cu a te gândi
la indicii primului vector ca
având o semnificație mai mare decât indicii celui de-al doilea vector,
deci poți vedea că
pe măsură ce parcurgem intrările produsului tensorial, avem toate produsele implicând prima intrare a
primului vector din stânga,
care este alpha unu. Apoi toate produsele
implicând a doua intrare a vectorului din stânga,
care este alpha doi și așa mai departe.
Iată un exemplu în care
vectorul din stânga are trei intrări și vectorul din
dreapta are patru intrări, astfel încât putem vedea mai
clar ce se întâmplă.
WEBVTT
Avem trei intrări în primul vector, deci începem prin a scrie trei copii ale celui de-al doilea vector și apoi înmulțim fiecare dintre acele copii
cu intrarea corespunzătoare
din primul vector astfel.
Aducem alfele înăuntru astfel, și aici pur și simplu
înmulțim vectori cu scalari
și în final îndepărtăm
parantezele din copii și formăm un singur vector
coloană, cum vezi chiar aici.
Ca o paranteză importantă, observă că avem următoarele formule pentru produsul tensorial al
vectorilor de bază standard.
Dacă luăm produsul
tensorial al ket a și ket b, pe care îl putem scrie cu
simbolul produsului tensorial sau fără, cum ai chiar aici,
atunci rezultatul este pur și simplu ket ab.
Dacă vrem să scriem ab ca o pereche ordonată în loc de un șir, putem face asta și obținem
această expresie chiar aici,
dar este mult mai comun
să scriem aceasta chiar here, în care lăsăm deoparte paranteza
dar lăsăm virgula.
Există un sens în care
aceasta cu paranteza este poate mai corectă, dar este o convenție destul de standard în matematică
că parantezele sunt îndepărtate când nu sunt necesare sau utile.
Te poți gândi la ele ca la implicit implicite în aceasta chiar here și este pur și simplu mai puțin aglomerat
și mai plăcut de privit.
Produsul tensorial are
o proprietate importantă care este că este biliniar și ceea ce înseamnă asta este că este liniar
în fiecare dintre cele două argumente, cu condiția că celălalt este fix.
În puțin mai mult detaliu, este
liniar în primul argument, ceea ce este exprimat prin aceste două ecuații pe care le vezi chiar aici,
prima spune că
dacă adunăm doi vectori, Phi1 și Phi2 și apoi luăm
produsul tensorial cu Psi, obținem același rezultat dacă
am fi luat produsul tensorial
cu Psi mai întâi și apoi am fi adunat.
A doua spune că dacă
înmulțim un vector oarecare Phi cu un scalar oarecare alpha și apoi luăm
produsul tensorial cu Psi,
rezultatul este același ca și cum am fi luat mai întâi produsul tensorial al lui Phi și Psi și apoi am fi înmulțit rezultatul cu alpha.
Și avem, de asemenea, liniaritate
în al doilea argument, care este același, cu excepția că rolurile celor două argumente sunt inversate.
Această proprietate de bilinearitate
este destul de simplă de verificat din definiție, dar este bine să o scriem astfel pentru că vom folosi des
aceste formule.
Observă de altfel că scalarii trec liber prin produsele tensoriale în sensul exprimat de aceste
egalități pe care le vezi chiar aici.
Adică nu există nicio diferență
între înmulțirea primului argument cu un
scalar alpha, în acest caz înmulțind al doilea
argument cu acel scalar
sau înmulțind întregul
lucru cu acel scalar.
Aceste egalități rezultă din
aceste două ecuații chiar here și pentru că nu există
nicio diferență între acești vectori, putem scrie pur și simplu
expresia cum ai chiar here
fără paranteze, deoarece
nu este nevoie de ele.
Ele nu adaugă nicio claritate
sau nu elimină nicio ambiguitate, deci le îndepărtăm pur și simplu și
obținem o expresie mai clară.
Toate acestea se generalizează
la trei sau mai multe sisteme.
Putem defini produsul tensorial
al trei sau mai mulți vectori prin generalizarea formulei
pentru produsul tensorial al doi vectori în mod natural,
ceea ce poți vedea exprimat chiar here. Fiecare intrare a produsului tensorial este dată de produsul intrărilor corespunzătoare
ale vectorilor din care
luăm produsul tensorial.
O modalitate echivalentă de
a defini produsul tensorial al trei sau mai mulți vectori
este să o facem recursiv, revenind în cele din urmă la definiția
produsului tensorial între doi vectori. Deci dacă n este cel puțin trei, ne putem gândi la
produsul tensorial al n vectori
Phi1 până la Phi n ca la produsul tensorial dintre orice vector obținem prin
luând produsul tensorial al primilor n minus unu dintre
ei cu ultimul vector,
și dacă vrei să știi
care este produsul tensorial al primilor n minus unu vectori, aplici din nou formula, în caz că n minus unu
este cel puțin trei sau folosești definiția
din înainte dacă n minus unu este egal cu doi.
Cele două moduri de a te gândi
la produsele tensoriale ale trei sau mai mulți vectori sunt echivalente.
De data aceasta când avem
trei sau mai mulți vectori din care luăm produsul tensorial, nu folosim termenul biliniar,
în schimb folosim termenul multiliniar,
dar ideea este aceeași.
Produsul tensorial este liniar
în fiecare dintre poziții, cu condiția că vectorii de
la toate celelalte poziții
sunt fixați. Trecând la măsurătorile
sistemelor multiple în stări probabilistice,
obținem imediat o specificație pentru cum funcționează măsurătorile
pentru sistemele multiple, pur și simplu gândindu-ne la ele
colectiv ca sisteme individuale
cu condiția că toate
sistemele sunt măsurate.
Ca un exemplu simplu, să presupunem că avem doi
biți X și Y și colectiv sunt în această stare probabilistică
chiar here,
pe care am văzut-o înainte. Firesc, dacă măsurăm
ambii acești biți, vom obține rezultatul 00
adică un zero pentru prima măsurătoare și un zero pentru a doua măsurătoare cu probabilitate o jumătate și vom obține rezultatul 1,1
WEBVTT
cu probabilitate o jumătate de asemenea. Este destul de simplu.
În esență, măsurarea tuturor sistemelor este echivalentă cu măsurarea
întregului sistem compus.
Dacă nu măsurăm toate
sistemele, totuși, ci în schimb măsurăm
doar unele dintre sisteme, atunci situația nu este
chiar atât de imediat clară
restricționând atenția noastră din nou la cazul a doar două
sisteme pentru a vedea esența a ceea ce se întâmplă în cel mai simplu context posibil.
Putem pune următoarea întrebare, să presupunem că avem două sisteme, X și Y, care sunt împreună ca o pereche
într-o anumită stare probabilistică particulară.
Ce se întâmplă dacă măsurăm
doar X și nu facem nimic cu Y?
Ei bine, putem răspunde la această întrebare folosind niște teorie de bază a probabilităților.
În primul rând, știm că probabilitatea că măsurătoarea
dă un anumit rezultat trebuie să fie dată de această formulă
pe care o vezi chiar here.
Putem să ne gândim la probabilitățile pentru fiecare dintre stările clasice
ale perechii XY ca și cum am fi măsurat amândouă și sumăm peste toate probabilitățile
care sunt consistente cu faptul că X se află în oricare stare clasică
a care ne interesează.
De aceea suma chiar here este doar peste stările clasice b ale lui Y.
O modalitate de a te gândi la această
formulă este că probabilitatea de a vedea o anumită stare clasică
a lui X dacă o măsurăm
trebuie să fie consistentă cu probabilitatea de a vedea acea stare dacă
am fi măsurat și Y, chiar dacă nu am făcut-o,
asta este foarte natural și intuitiv. Probabilitatea ca o măsurătoare a lui X să producă un anumit rezultat nu poate să depindă de dacă Y
a fost sau nu măsurat,
indiferent de rezultat.
Deci asta ne spune care sunt
probabilitățile pentru diferitele rezultate posibile
ale măsurătorii, dar ce se întâmplă cu Y sau cu
cunoașterea noastră despre Y ca rezultat?
Răspunsul este că ar putea exista în continuare
o incertitudine cu privire la starea lui Y ca
rezultat al faptului că am măsurat X
și am văzut un anumit rezultat. Iar acea incertitudine este reprezentată de această formulă chiar here pentru probabilitatea condițională
că Y se află într-o anumită
stare clasică b, dat că X se află într-o anumită stare clasică,
oricare stare clasică a,
pe care s-a întâmplat să o măsurăm.
Ca să fim precis, probabilitatea că Y se află
în o anumită stare clasică b, dat că X se află în starea clasică a,
este egală cu probabilitatea
că X se află în a și Y se află în b împărțit la probabilitatea că X
se află în starea clasică a.
Deci dacă măsurăm X, vom vedea
stări clasice diferite cu probabilități determinate
de această formulă chiar here
și în funcție de rezultatul pe care îl obținem, s-ar putea să avem în continuare o incertitudine despre starea clasică a lui Y și
acea incertitudine se reflectă
de această formulă chiar here.
Există de fapt o modalitate foarte ușoară
de a reformula toate acestea și de a efectua calcule
pentru cazuri specifice folosind notația Dirac
și merge astfel.
Începem prin a scrie
starea probabilistică a lui XY ca un vector astfel, și
aceasta este complet generală.
Intrările sunt notate cu Pab și acestea ar putea fi orice numere, atât timp cât întregul vector
este un vector de probabilitate.
Putem exprima ket ab ca un
produs tensorial cum ai chiar here și apoi putem folosi
bilinearitatea produsului tensorial
și mai precis faptul că este liniar în al doilea argument pentru a exprima acest vector
cum ai chiar here.
Ceea ce facem este să izolăm efectiv vectorii de bază standard
din partea stângă și să punem tot ce trebuie
în partea dreaptă
pentru a permite asta, deoarece asta va dezvălui ce se întâmplă când măsurăm primul sistem X.
Mai precis, probabilitatea
de a obține un anumit rezultat a este suma peste toate probabilitățile care apar în
paranteza de lângă ket a.
Și condiționat pe obținerea
unui anumit rezultat a, vectorul de probabilitate care descrie orice incertitudine rămâne cu privire la Y
este vectorul care era în
paranteze lângă a.
Cu excepția că trebuie să îl normalizăm pentru a-l face un vector de probabilitate și aceasta înseamnă că
trebuie să împărțim acel vector
la suma intrărilor din acel vector pentru a forma un vector de probabilitate.
Aici de altfel, suma este luată peste tot
c în gamma mai degrabă decât b doar pentru a folosi un alt nume de variabilă astfel încât să nu fie nicio confuzie
despre domeniul variabilelor,
dacă vrei.
Sumele din numărător
și numitor trebuie considerate ca lucruri separate și putem evita orice șansă
de confuzie în această privință
folosind variabile diferite
pentru cele două sume.
Iată un exemplu rapid pentru
a ilustra cum funcționează totul.
Să presupunem că XY este o pereche de biți în această stare probabilistică chiar here, pentru a înțelege ce se întâmplă
când măsurăm primul bit
și nu facem nimic cu al doilea, scriem vectorul cum ai chiar here, în care ket zero și ket
unu pe prima poziție
sunt izolați exact cum
am descris cu câteva momente în urmă.
Prima posibilitate este
că rezultatul măsurătorii este zero și probabilitatea
că se întâmplă asta este suma probabilităților
din interiorul parantezei
WEBVTT
care sunt tensored la ket zero. Deci obținem o doisprezecime plus o pătrime, care este o treime și
condiționat pe rezultatul zero.
Starea probabilistică a lui Y
devine acest vector normalizat sau echivalent împărțit la probabilitate
pe care tocmai am calculat-o, și deci ceea ce obținem este
acest vector chiar here.
A doua posibilitate este că rezultatul măsurătorii este unu și calculul este
făcut într-un mod similar, folosind al doilea termen din expresie
mai degrabă decât primul termen. Și dacă vrei să verifici detaliile, fă-o ca întotdeauna și oprește videoclipul pentru a-ți acorda un moment să faci asta.
Poți efectua același tip de calcule pentru a afla ce se întâmplă când
Y este măsurat în loc de X.
Este aceeași metodă sub rezerva unei simetrii între cele două sisteme.
De data aceasta scriem
vectorul de probabilitate astfel, izolând vectorii de bază standard în dreapta, cum ai chiar here,
dar altfel funcționează
exact la fel.
Poți folosi, de asemenea, această metodă
pentru mai mult de două sisteme.
Poate deveni puțin
dezordonat doar să scrii toate expresiile necesare, dar conceptual este
exact aceeași idee.
În final, pentru porțiunea lecției
despre informația clasică, vom arunca o privire la operațiile
pe stările probabilistice
ale sistemelor multiple. Urmând același raționament pe care l-am văzut de câteva ori.
Concluzionăm că operațiile probabilistice pe sisteme multiple sunt la fel
ca operațiile probabilistice pe sisteme individuale, reprezentate
prin matrice stocastice.
Dar de data aceasta acele matrice
au rânduri și coloane care corespund produsului cartezian al seturilor de stări clasice ale sistemelor individuale.
Adică privim pur și simplu
un sistem compus ca și cum ar fi un singur sistem și apelăm la descrierea pentru cum funcționează operațiile probabilistice
pentru sisteme individuale din
lecția anterioară.
Iată un exemplu de operație numită operație controlled-NOT
pe doi biți X și Y.
Aceasta este de fapt o operație deterministă și modul în care funcționează este
că dacă X este egal cu unu, atunci o operație NOT este efectuată pe Y
și altfel dacă X este egal
cu zero atunci nu se întâmplă nimic.
Bitul X este uneori
numit bit de control deoarece determină dacă
operația NOT este aplicată sau nu lui Y
și Y este numit bitul țintă deoarece este bitul pe care acționează operația NOT.
Poți, de asemenea, imagina
schimbând rolurile lui X și Y astfel încât Y să devină bitul de control
și X să devină ținta, dar aceea este o operație diferită
de cea descrisă here, deoarece operația nu este
simetrică între X și Y.
Ambele se numesc
operații controlled-NOT, și trebuie doar să specificăm
care dintre biți este bitul de control și
care este bitul țintă.
Această operație are acțiunea
pe care o vezi chiar here pe stările bazei standard și poți verifica acea
acțiune față de definiție
a operației. Și here este reprezentarea sa
matriceală a operației.
Când ne gândim la această operație, avem în vedere că există
acești doi biți separați și ei joacă rolurile pe care tocmai le-am descris cu
X ca bit de control
și Y ca bit țintă, dar nu există cu adevărat nimic
despre această acțiune here sau această reprezentare matriceală
care să ceară să
ne gândim la acești doi biți ca la biți separați.
Am putea alternativ pur și simplu
să ne gândim la această operație ca la o operație deterministă pe un sistem cu patru stări clasice
pe care am decis să le numim
0,0, 0,1, 1,0 și 1,1.
Iată un alt exemplu de
o operație probabilistică pe doi biți, care nu este o operație deterministă de data aceasta.
Operația setează Y să fie egal cu X cu probabilitate o jumătate și altfel merge în cealaltă direcție și setează X să fie egal cu Y.
Această operație nu are un nume special, este menită doar ca un exemplu.
Și here este reprezentarea
matriceală a acestei operații.
Poți vedea că poate fi exprimată ca o medie a două matrice, una care reprezintă operația
deterministă
în care Y este setat la orice
valoare stocată în X și cealaltă care setează
X să fie egal cu Y.
Deci here vedem că putem lua medii ale matricelor stocastice pentru a obține altele noi, la fel cum aveam în lecția anterioară.
Acum, să considerăm
următoarea întrebare. Să presupunem că avem două
operații probabilistice, fiecare pe propriul sistem
descrise ca de obicei prin matrice
stocastice și pentru a fi precis, să presupunem că M este
o operație probabilistică
pe un sistem X și N este o
operație probabilistică pe un sistem Y.
Întrebarea este dacă
efectuăm simultan M pe X și N pe Y, cum descriem
efectul pe care aceasta îl are
pe sistemul compus XY?
Gândindu-ne la asta
intuitiv pentru un moment, dacă efectuăm simultan
cele două operații pe propriile sisteme respective,
atunci efectuăm de fapt
o operație pe sistemul compus, deci ar trebui să fie descrisă
de o matrice stocastică.
Răspunsul scurt la această
întrebare este că matricea este obținută prin luarea unui produs tensorial, nu între vectori cum
am discutat mai devreme,
WEBVTT
ci între matrice, în acest
caz matricele M și N.
Deci să petrecem câteva momente
pentru a discuta produsele tensoriale ale matricelor și apoi vom
reveni la această întrebare.
Iată definiția
produsului tensorial între matrice și
este foarte analogă cu produsul tensorial între vectori.
Dacă presupunem că cele două
matrice cu care lucrăm sunt scrise în formele pe care le ai here, astfel încât intrările lui M sunt
notate alpha ab, cu a și b
variind peste un set de stări clasice sigma, iar intrările lui N sunt
notate beta cd, cu c și d
variind peste un set de stări clasice gamma.
Atunci produsul lui M și N este matricea pe care o ai chiar here.
Ceea ce avem este similar
cu produsul tensorial dintre vectori.
rândurile și coloanele lui M tensor N corespund perechilor de stări clasice care sunt scrise ca șiruri chiar here,
iar intrările sunt produse ale intrărilor corespunzătoare ale lui M și N.
Iată o altă modalitate de a scrie asta în termeni de intrările individuale
ale acestor matrice.
Intrarea ac bd a lui M tensor N este produsul intrării ab
din M și al intrării cd din N.
Există o altă modalitate de
a descrie M tensor N, care este că este
matricea unică ce transformă orice vector de forma Phi tensor Psi
în produsul tensorial al lui M aplicat la Phi cu N aplicat la Psi, și aceasta trebuie să fie adevărată pentru orice alegere
a acestor vectori Phi și Psi.
O modalitate de a gândi
asta este că produsul tensorial al matricelor se potrivește perfect cu produsul tensorial dintre vectori.
Aceasta este o ecuație pe care
ai spera în mod natural să fie adevărată și într-adevăr este.
În termeni de matrice scrise
explicit, putem defini produsul
tensorial cum ai chiar here.
Sunt multe puncte în această ecuație și sunt menite să
ilustreze pattern-ul, care este același pattern
pe care îl aveam pentru vectori, cu excepția că acum avem rânduri și coloane
în loc de doar vectori coloană.
În caz că nu este clar, exemplul
următor poate ajuta.
Vorbim here despre
produsul tensorial a două matrice 2 pe 2.
Mai întâi scriem patru
copii ale celei de-a doua matrice, câte una pentru fiecare intrare a primei matrice.
Înmulțim fiecare dintre aceste
copii ale celei de-a doua matrice cu intrarea corespunzătoare
a primei matrice,
și apoi le adunăm pe toate într-o
singură matrice 4 pe 4, cum ai chiar here.
Putem, de asemenea, defini
produsul tensorial al trei sau mai multor matrice într-un mod analog și poate cea mai ușoară
modalitate de a exprima asta
este cum ai chiar here
unde avem o formulă pentru fiecare intrare a produsului tensorial, care este pur și simplu produsul
intrărilor corespunzătoare.
Poți, de asemenea, defini produsul tensorial al trei sau mai multor matrice recursiv în termeni de produsul
tensorial a doar două matrice, la fel cum aveam pentru vectori.
Și o ultimă notă este
că produsul tensorial al matricelor este multiplicativ, ceea ce înseamnă că un
produs de produse tensoriale
este egal cu produsul tensorial
al produselor.
Te poți gândi la
asta ca la o generalizare a formulei de mai devreme pentru acțiunea produsului tensorial
al matricelor
pe produsul tensorial al vectorilor. Și din nou, aceasta este ceva ce
am dori cu siguranță să fie adevărat și putem fi bucuroși că este
și vom face uz de acest
fapt ori de câte ori avem nevoie.
Și acum putem reveni la
întrebarea din înainte care ne cere cum descriem
efectul efectuării unei operații M pe un sistem X
și a unei operații N pe sistemul Y împreună ca o operație
pe sistemul compus XY.
Și răspunsul la acea
întrebare este că acțiunea este descrisă de
produsul tensorial al lui M și N.
Produsele tensoriale reprezintă independența, de data aceasta între operații, spre deosebire de ceea ce am văzut
înainte pentru vectorii de probabilitate.
Iată un exemplu rapid. Să presupunem că efectuăm
operația probabilistică descrisă de această matrice pe un bit X.
Aceasta este de fapt o operație
pe care am văzut-o în lecția unu și simultan efectuăm
o operație NOT pe un bit Y.
Operația combinată pe perechea XY este astfel reprezentată de produsul tensorial al matricelor corespunzătoare acestor două operații.
Iată cel pe X și
here este operația NOT pe Y și obținem această matrice
pe care o ai chiar here.
Și poți vedea că într-adevăr
aceasta este o matrice stocastică și asta va fi întotdeauna cazul.
Produsul tensorial al oricăror
două matrice stocastice sau al oricărui număr de matrice
stocastice de altfel va fi întotdeauna stocastică.
Este o situație foarte comună
să întâlnim o situație în care o operație este
efectuată pe un sistem și nu se face nimic cu un alt sistem.
În această situație, urmăm exact aceeași prescripție cu înțelegerea că a nu face nimic este reprezentat de matricea identitate.
De exemplu, dacă avem doi biți X și
Y și resetăm bitul X la starea zero, care este același lucru
cu efectuarea funcției constante
zero pe X și nu facem nimic cu Y, atunci operația rezultantă pe perechea XY
WEBVTT
este reprezentată de acest
produs tensorial chiar here.
Toate acestea se generalizează
la orice număr de sisteme și vom vedea câteva exemple suplimentare când trecem la contextul cuantic, care funcționează exact la fel
cu excepția că avem matrice unitare în loc de matrice stocastice, și asta este suficient despre
informația clasică pentru moment.
Acum ne vom îndrepta atenția
spre informația cuantică și cum funcționează pentru sisteme multiple.
Pattern-ul este același ca
pentru informația clasică.
Putem privi sisteme cuantice multiple ca sisteme compuse individuale și aplica ceea ce știm
din lecția anterioară.
Din nou, produsele tensoriale
vor juca un rol cheie și în ansamblu obținem o descriere pentru cum funcționează informația cuantică
pentru sisteme multiple.
Care este foarte analog
și matematic similar cu ceea ce am văzut tocmai pentru
informația clasică.
Vom începe cu stările cuantice.
Stările cuantice ale sistemelor multiple sunt reprezentate de vectori coloană cu intrări de numere complexe
și normă euclidiană egală cu unu
la fel ca stările cuantice
ale sistemelor individuale.
De data aceasta indicii
vectorilor de stare cuantică corespund produsului cartezian al seturilor de stări clasice
ale sistemelor individuale
deoarece din nou, acesta este
setul de stări clasice al sistemului compus.
De exemplu, dacă X și Y sunt qubiți, atunci setul de stări clasice
pentru perechea XY împreună este produsul cartezian al
alfabetului binar cu el însuși,
pe care îl putem gândi ca
mulțimea tuturor șirurilor binare de lungime doi.
Deci acești vectori pe care îi ai here sunt toți exemple de vectori de
stare cuantică ai lui XY.
Dacă vrem, putem alternativ scrie
acești vectori astfel, în care avem un ket separat
pentru fiecare qubit
unde produsul tensorial
dintre ei este implicit.
Sau putem scrie, de asemenea,
simbolul produsului tensorial explicit astfel dacă preferi.
Și o altă opțiune este
de a subscripta ket-urile cu numele sistemelor
pe care le reprezintă astfel.
Și poți face asta cu
simbolul produsului tensorial sau fără.
Asta poate fi uneori foarte util pentru a menține claritatea.
Acestea sunt doar stiluri diferite pentru exprimarea acelorași vectori și putem alege pe care dorim sau pe care îl preferăm sau
pe care are cel mai mult sens
pentru situația dată. Când lucrurile devin mai
complicate de exemplu, s-ar putea să decidem că unul din
aceste stiluri adaugă claritate
și suntem liberi să facem
orice alegere dorim.
Produsele tensoriale ale vectorilor de stare cuantică sunt, de asemenea, vectori de stare cuantică.
Pentru cazul a două sisteme de exemplu, dacă Phi este un vector de stare cuantică
a unui sistem X și Psi este un vector de stare cuantică
a unui sistem Y,
atunci produsul tensorial al lui Phi și Psi este un vector de stare cuantică al lui XY.
Numim astfel de stări stări produs și similar cu ceea ce am văzut în contextul probabilistic clasic, ele reprezintă independența
dintre sistemele X și Y.
Deci de exemplu, dacă o persoană are un laborator
într-o parte a lumii și creează un sistem X și îl inițializează la starea cuantică Phi
și o altă persoană dintr-o
altă parte a lumii inițializează independent un sistem Y la starea cuantică Psi,
atunci dacă alegem să ne gândim la XY ca formând un singur sistem, chiar dacă este în două părți sau în părți diferite ale lumii,
atunci sistemul compus XY se află
în starea Phi tensor Psi.
Toate acestea se generalizează la
mai mult de două sisteme în mod natural.
Dacă avem stări
cuantice Psi1 până la PsiN ale sistemelor separate Xn până la Xn, atunci produsul tensorial al acestor n vectori
reprezintă o stare cuantică, care este din nou numită stare produs a sistemului compus X1 până la Xn.
Iată un exemplu de
stare cuantică a doi qubiți.
Deși s-ar putea să nu
pară imediat. Este un exemplu de stare produs deoarece o putem scrie
ca un produs tensorial cum ai chiar here.
Deci este un exemplu de
stare produs indiferent de cum este scrisă, ceea ce este relevant este dacă
este posibil sau nu să o scriem ca un produs tensorial.
Această stare cuantică, totuși, care este din nou o stare a doi
qubiți, nu este o stare produs.
Este similară în spirit cu
exemplul pe care l-am văzut în contextul probabilistic cu doi biți aleatori perfect corelați
și același argument arată că nu poate fi scrisă
ca un produs tensorial.
Deci să mutăm asta here și să aruncăm o privire la argument cu puțin mai mult detaliu.
Să ne imaginăm că
am putea scrie această stare ca un produs tensorial al
doi vectori Phi și Psi.
Intrarea corespunzătoare
stării clasice 0,1 este zero pentru acest vector, ceea ce putem vedea pur și simplu privind la el.
Aceasta ar implica totuși, dacă vectorul era un produs tensorial
al doi vectori, că intrarea zero a lui Phi
înmulțit cu intrarea unu a lui Psi
ar fi egală cu zero, dar aceasta înseamnă că fie
intrarea zero a lui Phi, fie intrarea unu a lui Psi este egală cu zero
sau amândouă ar putea fi egale cu zero, dar asta contrazice faptul
că aceste două produse de here trebuie să fie amândouă nenule.
WEBVTT
Sunt egale cu unu
pe radical din doi. Argumentul este de fapt destul de
similar cu ceea ce aveam în contextul probabilistic.
Nu există nimic unic
cuantic în asta.
În orice caz, ceea ce găsim este că starea originală nu este o stare produs.
Observă că nu este important
că aceste două numere de here sunt unu pe radical din doi.
Tot ce contează este că
ambele valori sunt nenule.
Această stare cuantică particulară
este una foarte interesantă. Este un exemplu de
stare entangled a doi qubiți.
Vom vorbi mai mult despre
entanglement mai târziu în serie.
Entanglementul poate fi complicat, mai ales când vorbim
despre stările cuantice în formularea generală
a informației cuantice,
dar here, în descrierea simplificată a informației cuantice, entanglementul este echivalent cu lipsa independenței.
Deci pentru un vector de stare cuantică,
dacă nu este o stare produs, este o stare entangled
și această stare particulară
este în mod obișnuit privită ca
exemplul arhetipal al unei stări cuantice entangled.
Și de fapt, uneori
ne gândim la această stare ca reprezentând o unitate de entanglement, mai ales când ne gândim la entanglement
ca la o resursă care poate fi
folosită pentru a face lucruri interesante.
Starea cuantică despre care
tocmai am vorbit este una din cele patru așa-numite stări Bell, pe care le poți vedea here
împreună cu numele
care sunt folosite în mod obișnuit pentru aceste stări, Phi plus, Phi minus,
Psi plus și Psi minus.
Toate sunt entangled
și formează o bază pentru spațiul tuturor
vectorilor reprezentând stări ale doi qubiți.
Deci acești patru vectori împreună
sunt numiți baza Bell.
Este o colecție de stări cuantice
întâlnită foarte frecvent, numită
în cinstea lui John Bell, care a fost un fizician ce a adus
contribuții foarte importante
la studiul entanglementului în anii 1960.
Iată câteva exemple binecunoscute de stări cuantice ale trei qubiți.
Primul se numește starea GHZ.
Este un fel de analog al stării Phi
plus pe care tocmai am văzut-o, dar pentru trei qubiți în loc de doi.
Și al doilea exemplu se numește starea W și arată cum ai here, deci este uniformă peste
cele trei șiruri binare
de lungime trei care au
exact un bit setat la unu.
Niciuna din aceste stări nu este o stare produs și ambele au proprietăți interesante și apar destul de frecvent ca exemple, deci e bine să le cunoști
și le vom mai vedea.
Urmează să vorbim despre
măsurătorile sistemelor în stări cuantice.
Urmând același raționament
pe care l-am urmat până acum în lecție, care este să ne gândim la sisteme multiple
ca și cum ar fi sisteme individuale. Ajungem imediat la o descriere pentru cum funcționează măsurătorile
sistemelor cuantice multiple
cu condiția că toate
sistemele sunt măsurate.
Adică dacă avem un
vector de stare cuantică Psi care reprezintă o stare cuantică
a unui n-tuplu de sisteme
X1 până la Xn și măsurăm
întregul sistem compus, care este echivalent cu măsurarea
fiecăruia dintre sistemele individuale, atunci fiecare n-tuplu posibil
de stări clasice va fi rezultatul măsurătorii
cu probabilitate egală cu
valoarea absolută la pătrat a intrării din Psi care
corespunde acelui n-tuplu.
De exemplu, dacă avem
o pereche de sisteme XY în această stare cuantică chiar here, atunci dacă măsurăm ambele sisteme,
atunci vom obține rezultatul zero inimă, adică zero pentru măsurătoarea lui X și inimă pentru măsurătoarea lui Y
cu probabilitate nouă douăzeci și cincimi și vom obține rezultatul unu
pică cu probabilitate 16/25.
Asta este destul de simplu. Ignorăm esențialmente faptul că acestea sunt două sisteme separate și le privim ca și cum
sunt un singur sistem,
dar asta ridică
următoarea întrebare naturală, pe care am considerat-o deja
în contextul clasic.
Să presupunem că avem două sisteme X și Y care sunt colectiv
într-o stare cuantică și nu le măsurăm pe ambele, ci
măsurăm doar un sistem.
Să spunem că măsurăm sistemul X și nu facem nimic cu Y.
Desigur, putem, de asemenea, întreba ce se întâmplă dacă măsurăm Y și nu
X și mai general ce se întâmplă dacă avem
trei sau mai multe sisteme
și măsurăm o submulțime proprie a lor. Dar odată ce avem un
răspuns la această întrebare, vom avea răspunsuri și la
acelea.
Știm că în general
un vector de stare cuantică a perechii XY ia
forma pe care o ai chiar here, presupunând ca de obicei că sigma și gamma
sunt seturile de stări clasice
ale lui X și Y respectiv.
Intrările acestui vector sunt
notate alpha ab, variind peste toate alegerile posibile de a și b,
și pot fi orice număr complex care face ca acest vector
să fie un vector unitar.
Acum știm deja că dacă
ambele sisteme sunt măsurate, atunci obținem probabilitățile pentru diferitele rezultate posibile
WEBVTT
luând valoarea absolută la pătrat a intrării corespunzătoare.
Și deci dacă este măsurat doar X, atunci probabilitatea de a
obține un anumit rezultat a este dată de această expresie,
pur și simplu sumăm peste toate
rezultatele posibile b, care ar putea fi obținute
dacă Y ar fi fost și el măsurat, chiar dacă nu a fost.
Ideea este aceeași ca în
contextul probabilistic.
Probabilitatea de a obține
un anumit rezultat când X este măsurat nu poate
să depindă de dacă Y a fost sau nu măsurat.
Deci asta ne spune care sunt
probabilitățile pentru diferitele rezultate posibile.
În plus, va exista o
schimbare în starea lui Y ca urmare a fi
efectuat această măsurătoare pe X și a fi obținut un anumit rezultat.
Deci să vedem cum funcționează asta.
Similar cu ceea ce am făcut în
contextul probabilistic, putem exprima
vectorul de stare cuantică Psi cum ai chiar here
unde Phi a este acest vector pentru fiecare alegere de stare clasică a a sistemului X,
folosim bilinearitatea
produsului tensorial exact ca înainte.
Doar că acum am ales să numim
acești vectori diferiți Phi a, doar pentru comoditate.
Am observat deja că probabilitatea ca măsurătoarea să producă
fiecare rezultat posibil a este cum ai chiar here,
dar acum putem vedea că această probabilitate este egală cu norma euclidiană
la pătrat a vectorului Phi a,
și acum ca urmare a măsurătorii lui X dând un anumit rezultat a, avem că starea cuantică
a sistemului compus XY
devine această stare pe care
o ai chiar here.
La fel cum aveam pentru sistemele individuale, starea colapsează în esență, dar nu colapsează
complet în general,
colapsează doar atât cât trebuie pentru a fi consistentă
cu măsurătoarea lui X dând rezultatul a.
Starea cuantică a lui Y devine Phi a normalizat, adică
împărțim la norma sa euclidiană
astfel încât să devină un vector unitar. Aceasta este analogă cu ceea ce s-a întâmplat în
contextul probabilistic, în care în loc de a împărți
la norma euclidiană,
împărțeam la suma
intrărilor lui Phi a pentru a obține un vector de probabilitate.
Dar here, pentru că vorbim
despre stări cuantice, împărțim la norma euclidiană
pentru a obține un vector de stare cuantică.
Să aruncăm o privire la câteva exemple pentru a vedea cum funcționează asta
pentru o stare specifică.
Iată starea pe care o vom considera. Presupunem că X și Y sunt qubiți și se află în această stare particulară Psi.
Și să presupunem că X este măsurat.
Începem prin a scrie starea
Psi cum ai chiar here, izolând efectiv factorii de bază standard ai lui X
și tensoring-ând cu tot ce trebuie pentru a obține starea originală.
La fel ca în descrierea generală
de mai devreme.
Probabilitatea de a obține rezultatul zero este norma euclidiană la pătrat
a acestui vector chiar here.
Lucrul cu care facem tensoring la ket zero în expresia noastră a vectorului Psi.
Și deci probabilitatea este trei sferturi și condiționat pe
obținerea rezultatului zero.
Starea cuantică a
perechii XY devine aceasta, în care normalizăm
vectorul tensor cu ket zero,
și asta este echivalent cu
împărțirea la rădăcina pătrată din probabilitatea pe care
tocmai am calculat-o.
Putem apoi simplifica
și asta este ceea ce obținem.
Probabilitatea de a obține
rezultatul unu al măsurătorii se calculează într-un mod similar.
Luăm norma euclidiană la pătrat
a acestui vector chiar here. Lucrul cu care facem tensoring la ket
unu în expresia noastră a lui Psi
și probabilitatea
rezultantă este un sfert, ceea ce trebuie să fie, desigur, pentru că probabilitățile
noastre trebuie să sumeze la unu.
În acest caz, starea cuantică a lui XY devine aceasta, în care din nou normalizăm împărțind la norma euclidiană
astfel încât să obținem acest vector de
stare cuantică ca rezultat.
Aceeași metodă este folosită
într-un mod simetric, dacă Y este măsurat în loc de X.
Iată vectorul de stare cuantică original, și de data aceasta, deoarece Y
este măsurat în loc de X,
exprimăm vectorul Psi
cum ai chiar here, în care de data aceasta izolăm vectorii de bază standard ai lui Y
mai degrabă decât X, tensoring-ând
cu tot ce trebuie pentru a obține o expresie a lui Psi.
Parcurgând calculul, pe care îl poți verifica prin
oprind videoclipul dacă vrei.
Vedem că probabilitatea
de a obține rezultatul zero este cinci optime de data aceasta, și here este vectorul de stare cuantică
care rezultă condiționat
pe obținerea acelui rezultat.
Și probabilitatea de a obține
rezultatul unu este trei optime, caz în care acesta este
vectorul nostru de stare cuantică.
Poți folosi exact aceeași metodă în caz că ai mai mult de două sisteme și o submulțime proprie a lor este măsurată.
WEBVTT
Și există un exemplu
în conținutul manualului pentru această lecție pe care
îl poți consulta dacă ești interesat.
Pe scurt, putem întotdeauna împărți sistemele în două colecții separate, cele care sunt măsurate
și cele care nu sunt.
Și odată ce am făcut asta, apelăm la metoda
metodă pe care tocmai am descris-o, și astfel funcționează măsurătorile pentru sisteme cuantice multiple.
Și acum în final, trecem la operații unitare
pe sisteme multiple.
Folosind aceeași idee de bază că sistemele multiple pot fi privite ca sisteme compuse individuale.
Concluzionăm ceea ce ai
scris here pe ecran, operațiile cuantice pe sisteme compuse sunt reprezentate de matrice unitare
la fel cum avem pentru sistemele individuale și mai precis rândurile și coloanele acelor matrice unitare corespund produsului cartezian
al seturilor de stări clasice ale oricărei colecții de
sisteme despre care vorbim.
De exemplu, dacă avem un sistem X
ale cărui stări clasice sunt unu, doi și trei și Y este un qubit,
atunci matricea pe care o ai chiar here este un exemplu de matrice unitară care reprezintă o
operație pe perechea XY.
Detaliile despre cum
ordonăm produsele carteziene despre care am vorbit înainte nu contează cu adevărat pentru
scopul acestui exemplu, este pur și simplu o matrice 6 pe 6
care se întâmplă să fie unitară.
Nu există nimic special în ea, deși este construită din câteva
matrice importante.
Ideea este că ai putea
alege orice matrice unitară 6 pe 6 și ar reprezenta
o operație unitară pe XY.
Dacă aplicăm o colecție de
operații unitare independent, fiecare pe propriul sistem, atunci acțiunea tuturor împreună
pe sistemul compus este
dată de produsul tensorial.
Și here pe ecran poți vedea o formulare mai precisă
a acelui fapt.
Dacă operațiile noastre unitare sunt descrise de matricele unitare U1 până la Un, câte una pentru fiecare dintre sistemele noastre,
atunci acțiunea combinată
pe sistemul compus este dată de produsul
tensorial al lui U1 până la Un.
Din nou, similar cu ceea ce aveam în contextul probabilistic, un exemplu important este că
aplicăm o operație unitară
U unui sistem X și nu
facem nimic cu un alt sistem Y.
Operația pe XY care rezultă este U tensored cu matricea identitate.
Matricea identitate
descrie a nu face nimic cu Y.
Uneori este util să scriem explicit că această matrice identitate
corespunde sistemului Y, doar pentru a face formulele mai clare.
Și o opțiune este de a
da matricei identitate un subscript ca acesta care indică sistemul pe care acționează.
Când este suficient de clar, de obicei nu
ne ostenim cu un subscript, dar când lucrurile devin mai complicate, poate fi foarte util.
Și putem, de asemenea, considera
cazul simetric în care o operație unitară
V este aplicată lui Y și nu se face nimic cu X,
și de data aceasta operația
unitară rezultantă pe XY, este reprezentată de acest
produs tensorial here.
Și din nou, putem pune un subscript pe
matricea identitate dacă ajută.
Iată câteva exemple specifice.
Dacă X și Y sunt qubiți și
efectuăm o operație Hadamard pe X și nu facem nimic cu Y, obținem matricea pe care o ai chiar here.
Dacă pe de altă parte, efectuăm operația Hadamard pe Y și nu facem nimic cu X, ordinea produsului tensorial este inversată.
Și deci obținem matricea
pe care o ai chiar here.
Nu orice operație unitară
pe un sistem compus poate fi exprimată ca un produs tensorial.
Dacă avem un produs tensorial,
atunci avem independență.
Și există câteva exemple destul de
fundamentale de operații care cu siguranță
nu acționează independent pe sisteme multiple.
De exemplu, dacă X și Y au
același set de stări clasice, care ar putea fi orice
set de stări clasice sigma,
atunci ne putem gândi la
operația swap pe perechea XY.
Această operație nu schimbă ordinea celor două sisteme, avem în continuare X în
stânga și Y în dreapta, ci mai degrabă reprezintă
schimbul conținutului
celor două sisteme. Here poți vedea că este exprimată
sub forma unei ecuații în care avem un
produs tensorial a două stări cuantice.
O altă modalitate de a o scrie este ca
o matrice, cum ai chiar here.
Modul în care te poți gândi
la această descriere este că îți spune ce se întâmplă pentru vectorii de bază standard.
Și odată ce știm ce se întâmplă
pentru vectorii de bază standard, știm ce se întâmplă pentru
stările cuantice arbitrare prin liniaritate,
ceea ce este de fapt adevărat și pentru
această expresie chiar here.
Deci această operație particulară chiar here se întâmplă să fie și o operație deterministă și o operație unitară.
Dacă X și Y sunt qubiți de exemplu, obținem această reprezentare
matriceală chiar here.
Iată o conexiune interesantă
între operația swap și cele patru stări Bell, care sunt prezentate chiar
here pentru comoditate.
Operația swap lasă
primele trei dintre ele neschimbate, dar pune un semn minus în
fața stării Psi minus,
WEBVTT
deci există ceva
special în legătură cu aceea.
Poți verifica aceste ecuații direct privind la acești vectori și considerând ce se întâmplă
pentru stările de bază standard
schimbând cele două stări clasice pentru primele trei stări Bell
nu face nimic, obținem aceeași stare cu care am început.
În al patrulea caz totuși, semnul minus se mută efectiv
de la un termen la altul când efectuăm swap-ul stărilor clasice,
și asta este echivalent cu înmulțirea vectorului cu minus unu.
Deci efectuarea operației swap scoate cumva un semn minus
din această a patra stare Bell.
Vom mai spune despre
aceste ecuații mai târziu, dar acum să trecem la
un alt tip de operație, care este o operație controlată.
Vom presupune că X este un qubit și Y este orice sistem dorești.
Dacă U este o operație unitară pe Y, atunci o operație controlled U pe XY este operația
exprimată chiar here.
Mai întâi, folosind notația Dirac și apoi folosind ceea ce se numește o matrice bloc, îți imaginezi că completezi această matrice mai mare
cu cele mai mici, în care aceste zerouri reprezintă cu adevărat matrice
umplute cu zerouri.
Deci fiecare dintre aceste patru blocuri reprezintă o matrice cu un număr
de rânduri și coloane care corespunde numărului
de stări clasice ale lui Y.
Ideea unei operații controlate, pe care am întâlnit-o deja
în contextul clasic când am discutat o
operație controlled-NOT,
este că dacă X este setat la zero,
atunci nu se întâmplă nimic cu Y.
Dar dacă X este setat la unu,
atunci U este aplicat lui Y.
Deci X se numește qubit de control, și Y se numește sistemul țintă, care în general nu
trebuie să fie un qubit.
Ca un exemplu specific,
pe care tocmai l-am menționat, avem o operație controlled-NOT.
Dacă primul qubit este setat
la zero, nu se întâmplă nimic. Și dacă primul qubit este setat la unu, atunci o operație NOT sau echivalent,
o operație sigma X este
aplicată celui de-al doilea qubit.
Și here este reprezentarea sa matriceală.
Vorbim here despre doi qubiți, deci am putea la fel de bine
decide că al doilea qubit este controlul și
primul este ținta.
Pentru a descrie acea operație, pur și simplu inversăm ordinea
în produsul tensorial, iar rezultatul este matricea
pe care o ai chiar here.
Dacă în loc de o operație controlled-NOT, considerăm o operație controlled sigma
Z sau controlled Z.
Obținem această reprezentare
matriceală chiar here. Și pentru aceasta, nu contează cu adevărat
care este controlul și care este ținta.
Obținem același rezultat în ambele cazuri.
Putem merge mai departe și putem considera o operație controlled swap.
Și here vorbim
despre swap-ul a doi qubiți, deci ajungem cu trei qubiți când includem qubit-ul de control.
Fiecare reprezentare matriceală
arată astfel.
Este o operație destul de specială și este cunoscută ca operație Fredkin, sau mai frecvent gate Fredkin.
Când ne gândim la ea
ca la un gate într-un circuit, vom discuta circuit-urile în lecția următoare.
Ultimul exemplu este o operație controlled,
controlled-NOT, care este din nou o
operație pe trei qubiți.
Și here este reprezentarea sa matriceală. Această operație este mult mai bine
cunoscută ca operație Toffoli sau gate Toffoli.
Vom discuta mai mult despre ea
și vom vedea de ce atât ea cât și operația Fredkin sunt operații foarte importante
în o lecție ulterioară.
Și acesta este sfârșitul celei de-a doua lecții. În această lecție, am discutat cum funcționează informația cuantică pentru sisteme multiple.
Sper că te vei alătura mie pentru
a treia lecție în curând, care este despre circuit-uri cuantice,
protocoale și jocuri.
La revedere până atunci.